bienvenue dans vue de Russie sur France
24 votre chronique hebdomadaire qui
analyse la propagande de Vladimir
Poutine sur fond de guerre en Ukraine
avec Elena boloshin bonsoir Elena
bonsoir Stéphane le ministère russe de
la Défense clame donc la prise de
Solidar avant-hier déjà le chef de la
société militaire privée Wagner
prigogne revendiquait je cite la
libération totale de cette vie
ukrainienne alors comment les chaînes de
télévision russes couvrent-elles cet
événement alors qu'il y a quelques mois
encore la société Wagner était
totalement tabou dans les médias russes
puisque illégal en Russie oui vous avez
entièrement raison Stéphanie on va en
parler mais on va s'arrêter d'abord sur
ce terme de Libération il est important
à relever puisqu'il faut toujours
rappeler que la Russie écrit cette
histoire de la guerre en Ukraine à
l'envers en prétendant libérer l'Ukraine
et non pas l'envahir et l'occuper la
libérer de quoi de prétendu à nazi et
encore hier soir la présentatrice
vedette Olga scabeva elle employait ce
terme nous sommes sur la chaîne étatique
Rossi à 1 l'émission phare d'actualité
minutes écoutez
nous venons d'apprendre que les forces
armées ukrainiennes ont tenté une
contre-offensive près de solédar de son
Asie ont été liquidés la suite après la
pub
voilà donc c'est une réalité parallèle
admise et acquise en Russie armée
ukrainienne égale nazi dès lors ce
discours de libération de l'Ukraine qui
ne fait aucun sens dans la vraie vie
puisqu'il s'agirait de libérer l'Ukraine
des Ukrainiens mais ce discours il fait
écho dans l'esprit de nombreux Russes
qui sont marqués par cette récupération
permanente de la victoire
dans la seconde guerre mondiale contre
les nazis opère la propagande russe une
libération donc selon ce discours et
voyez comment Alexandre sladcoff il est
présenté comme le premier journaliste
rue ça avoir pénétré à solidaire par la
télévision russe ce reportage a été
diffusé hier soir il est mbz embarqué
comme on dit dans notre jargon
télévisuel avec une unité de combattants
russe un peu particulière regardez
soledar n'est pas seulement pris sous
contrôle elle est encerclée par des
brigades d'assaut russe qui ont libéré
la ville
n'importe quelle tentative des forces
armées ukrainiennes de rentrer à nouveau
dans solédar est exclu mon orchestre
travaille au complet chaque violon joue
sa note au bon moment et au bon endroit
les libérateurs de la ville ont huissé
leur drapeau
[Musique]
donc là ce sont bien les combattantes de
Wagner et Lena qui se font appeler les
musiciens l'orchestre au complet dit-il
oui effectivement mais vous remarquerez
qu'on voit les insignes dans le
reportage mais que jamais ce nom de
Wagner
l'ambiguïté plane en fait aujourd'hui
quand on fait de savoir si les
propagandistes de la télévision russe
ont le droit ou non de citer ouvertement
le nom de Wagner il se trouve qu'avant
le début de cette grande offensive qui a
lancé Vladimir Poutine le 24 février
dernier et bien ce nom était
complètement passé sous silence par la
propagande officielle russe pour cause
le mercenaria et légalement interdit en
Russie donc le pouvoir a d'abord démenti
l'existence de cette société puis le
fait d'y avoir recours et l'homme
d'affaires yevini prigogi lui a toujours
démenti le fait d'en être le chef mais
au fur et à mesure de la guerre les
tabous sont un peu tombés parce que les
combattants de Wagner ont pris une part
active au combat alors la propagande
russe a choisi de les mettre en scène
jouant à la fois sur la démystification
de la légende et la sur la construction
d'une image de guerriers
ultra professionnel et performant les
reportage de la télévision russe
consacrée à Wagner reste rare en voici
un daté du 6 novembre dernier on est au
coeur des combats pour la prise de cette
ville de barmouth que les rustantes de
conquérir depuis l'été dernier regardez
le violon sur la façade de l'immeuble
veut dire conquis par les musiciens les
combattants de Wagner il ramène un
blessé de la ligne de front ou les
combats acharnés font rage depuis deux
jours le médecin qui le soigne est un
ancien prisonnier qui a décidé de
regagner sa liberté en servant son pays
au sein de Wagner c'est un bon projet
dur mais bon
notre objectif est de prendre barmoutez
nous le prendrons quel que soit les
effectifs de l'ennemi en face les
musiciens rentrent vers les lignes
ennemis deux d'entre sont blessés leur
retraite est couvertes ils ont pris ces
positions par la ruse en venant par
derrière en se faisant passer pour du
renfort on est plus fort que sur la
psychologie
site Wagner mais on voit que le
journaliste n'emploie pas le terme de
mercenaire pour qualifier ses
combattants puisque le mercenariat est
interdit en Russie oui exactement et ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ne parle
pas de mercenaire lorsqu'ils parlent de
ce Wagner mais ce même reportage
souligne qu'il y a bien des mercenaires
en face dans le camp ukrainien et tout
le discours vise à condamner se fait
regarder cette autre extrait
plus personne ne doute du fait que des
mercenaires combats du côté ukrainien
voilà une preuve de plus il en fallait
cette phrase ou à sauvage sur l'une des
positions abandonnées et oui c'est bien
bataillon de mercenaire qui était
disloqué ici alors que sous-entend ce
discours et bien tout simplement le fait
que côté ukrainien ne se battrait pas
pour la cause mais pour l'argent la
propagande russe elle traite
particulièrement durement et avec
dérision tous les étrangers et notamment
les Occidentaux qui combattent en
Ukraine et qualifient d'ailleurs
indistinctement et à tort les ceux qui
s'engagent bénévolement par exemple dans
la légion internationale ukrainienne qui
appartient à l'armée régulière
ukrainienne elle est qualifie quand même
de mercenaires écoutez à ce titre cet
échange assez surréaliste il a été
diffusé il y a trois jours par quelqu'un
que nous connaissons bien Stéphanie
Vladimir soloviop une star de la
propagande russe le présentateur vedette
il s'est rendu dans le don basse et il
affirme s'entretenir avec des membres de
la 155e brigade d'infanterie de marine
Horus regardez
[Musique]
alors voilà ça se passe de commentaires
et par opposition Vladimir soloff il ne
cache pas son admiration quand il parle
des combattants de Wagner il n'a pas
peur lui de les nommer ni de les évoquer
pour cause c'est un proche de Vladimir
Poutine il interview régulièrement il
anime une émission hebdomadaire qui est
consacrée au président russe à sa gloire
et il y a un mois il s'est a donné à son
exercice favori qu'on vient de voir il
est allé voir il est il était encore
dans le combat c'est cette fois
précisément il allait voir les
combattants de Wagner écoutez comment il
a ensuite relaté cette rencontre dans
l'une de ses multiples émissions à la
télévision russe l'émission hebdomadaire
du dimanche soir regardez
les combattants de la légendaire société
Wagner sont venus chacun d'entre eux
mériterait un film
qu'est-ce qui différencie les musiciens
des autres gens qui combattent sur le
front
il ne recule pas jamais sous aucun
prétexte il ne se rende pas
j'ai parlé avec l'un des commandants les
plus célèbres un héros multi décoré
c'est un idéaliste il est fin
intelligent c'est un dieu de la guerre
par hasard il y avait aussi là-bas le
héros de la Russie le dirigeant enfin
celui qu'on dit être le dirigeant
monsieur Prigogine il y avait le célèbre
Wagner en personne monsieur hodkine j'ai
pu leur parler ils ont le sens de
l'humour et bien sûr ils savent pourquoi
l'orgas sont prêts à mourir pour eux
peux-tu nous en est parce qu'ils sont
avec eux donc
donc on voit bien ce levier offre qui
chante les louanges de Wagner Elena
quelques mots peut-être sur les figures
dont il parle bon Prigogine qu'on
connaît un petit peu et puis Dimitri
outkine qu'on connaît moins oui alors ça
c'est l'ironie de l'histoire puisque le
chef militaire de Wagner celui qui
participe à des nazifiés l'Ukraine selon
la terminologie officielle russe et bien
il arbore lui-même c'est un néonazi
notoire regardez il arbore des tatouages
notamment en néo-nazis l'aigle du
troisième rail chez l'emblème SS quand
tu as pris goji celui qu'on dit être le
dirigeant de Wagner vous l'avez entendu
comme dit ce love Yoff dans cet extrait
pour toujours entretenir un petit peu
cette ce secret de polichinelle il est
sorti de l'ombre il a même défrayé la
chronique en recrutant à tour de bras
des tenues condamnés pour crime grave
dans les prisons russes et fin décembre
par contre ces combattants ils ont
dilapidé en public ce mythe qui
bâtissait la grande armée russe un
puissante sur entraînée sur équipé dans
une vidéo devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est combattants ils ont
invectivé en personne le chef de
l'état-major russe Valérie guerassimov
écoutez
au chef de l'état-major T1D t'es un
diable de merde on doit combattre on n'a
pas de munitions les gars là-bas meurent
pour nous et on est là assis [__] on
aide pas on a besoin de munitions on
veut tous les baiser ici près de ton
combat toute l'armée ukrainienne tu es
où êtes nous à la fin
on a pas d'autres mots pour te qualifier
t'es un [__] où êtes-vous tous quand nos
gamers
pour hallucinant évidemment insulter son
chef des armées en personne ça c'est
vraiment jamais vu en Russie dans la
Russie de New yorkoutine oui d'ailleurs
c'est passé assez mal revers de bâton ce
même Valérie guerassimov traité de ce
nom dans cette vidéo et bien il vient
d'être nommé chef des opérations en
Ukraine s'il en fallait peut-être c'est
un message envoyé par Vladimir Poutine
aïevini Prigogine pour que chacun
respecte son rôle dans cette verticale
du pouvoir russe de son côté il y avait
gagné Prigogine n'a sans doute pas dit
son dernier mot au vu du rôle qu'on lui
connaît désormais dans la guerre
militaire comme informationnelle merci
Elena et à la semaine prochaine